hi I'm Nick Offerman and today I'm going
undercover on a place I dislike the
Internet it's actually me I'm not even
good at opening laptops let's start with
Twitter hey Nick Offerman where does
this moustache rate on the Ron Swanson
scale 3 out of 100 cent Nick Offerman I
made a bat on the lathe what do you
think small to small it was my first
headshot all anyone really needs is a
young Nick Offerman to grow with I don't
know I I could do without the earring
props on the mutton chops officially
posted YouTube many people are saying
that we are a divided nation Offerman
2020 I don't think so I am NOT a
lawmaker I'm not trained in the law I
don't think a blowhard performer from
NBC should ever consider running for
office it seems like common sense to me
sit why does he use a tumbler instead of
a Glencairn is he a barbarian if a
vessel holds a beverage without spilling
or dripping then I consider it an
appropriate vessel Wikipedia Wikipedia
that is actually me Offerman is a
die-hard Chicago Cubs and Chicago Bears
fan he and his wife played guitar
together in their free time I would call
myself a die-hard Cubs fan I'm not a
die-hard Bears fan I don't watch a lot
of football my wife and I like to do
puzzles together in our free time and
make sweet slow languorous love and
enter Instagram
I think my neighbor's cat bears a
resemblance to one of my favorite Pawnee
public employees I'll take that as a
compliment
transmission complete mr. Offerman aka
Ron Swanson is healing up nicely
come at me with more portraits this is a
very well rendered tattoo of my face on
human flesh and I will try to continue
living my life in a way that you're not
one day sorry I know what I'm about son
not sure you do know what you're about
that is a pretty attractive rendering of
my several Chin's but I'm not sure that
Ron whatever were that shirt and what
what planet is behind him fascinating
thank you my new Ron Swanson tattoo on
my forearm hope you have a fine
collection of long-sleeved shirts
appreciate the the bacon heart your work
is true and I wish you a long life got
to do this Ron Swanson RRP Lily
thanks so much lady it was lots of fun
there's a rather a maritime quality to
this tattoo as well as a an uncooked
steak of which I applaud scent read it
officially on the Internet's I'm a 23
year old black male and all I want in
life is to be Ron Swanson don't tell me
it's not possible don't please it's not
possible how long has he been doing this
how powerful is he how long has he been
doing what and he's probably medium
powerful IMDB
my IMDB trademarks are characters that
express a large amount of machismo
deadpan style delivery and moustache a
fourth trademark I would add is
surprisingly graceful dancer posted what
is the most badass thing about Nick
Offerman his readiness to cry submit is
there anybody in real life like Ron
Swanson
probably not he's a brilliant fictional
creation of some really smart comedy
writers he wouldn't be that appetizing
of a person he'd have high points but
generally would be pretty boring and
pedantic response transmitted Yahoo
Answers is Nick Offerman really a
libertarian while I admire the
philosophy of the libertarian mindset I
think it's proven to be ineffectual in
actual governance so no I am NOT I'm a
free-thinking American cent who would
win in a fight Chuck Norris or Ron
Swanson good question
probably Chuck Norris he's a trained
fighter and Ron Swanson is a government
bureaucrat who can throw a punch but I
think training would win out in the end
enter do women like good mustaches some
do some don't there's no accounting for
taste
it's actually me more Cora does Nick
Offerman really play the saxophone
I do really play the saxophone not
nearly as well as Duke silver I started
on the baritone sax in fifth grade and
became a pretty competent tenor sax
player ass at first chair in my high
school's jazz band and won the Louie
Armstrong jazz award upon graduation in
1988 and I believe that was considered
the peak of my own saxophone career
which actors have been influenced by
Nick Offerman now how in the world would
I know the answer to that question
Anthony Hopkins
I would guess has been influenced by me
Meryl Streep I've noticed she's mimicked
some of my facial tics which I take as a
compliment and Benedict Cumberbatch
started using facial hair in some of his
recent movies so you tell me in four
words what is Nick Offerman like in real
life
coquettish cute as hell that's it for
now I hope that I answered some of your
questions and I've once again confirmed
that the Internet is not where I would
like to be oops hang on